groundbreakers radiators only the board
has access to they want us to sweat
thinking that'll soften me up the board
isn't helping and my resources are
spread reasonable huh according to my
grandmother's old schematics the parts
we need hold on the back bays are on a
lower deck good
damnit bread were you expecting any
company look at this right Pete time to
feed is this what carbon monoxide I
neighbor from above it's a cattle it
that's right sir just the parts Dennison
just keeps feeding the furnace don't she
you don't just ask a king for a favor
when your stick under its skin this [ __ ]
you've got the run of the kingdom up
those stairs you'll find the parts Mike
smells kind of like old busses helps on
pipes
wake up gonna be pleased as pie when we
show her these
this is how seon do you've returned good
work
I'll take those I need you to head
through the large door at the far end of
engineering take there's a terminal on
the back activate it when I call a
physician don't worry me I'm genuine
[Music]
[Music]
my boards are returning to the tub if
you've got time I believe Edna has a
comms issue that could use your
attention I've also authorised doc and
Peru to sell you our premium meds
[Music]
[Applause]
you